when generally when you think about the
term intelligence you're talking about
what's the difference between Einstein
and a normal person or between a normal
person and stick the person but actually
it's like what's the difference between
a normal person and a mouse
what's the difference between a mouse
and a rock-like that's the that's the
difference in between just levels of
intelligence within humans which
actually doesn't vary that much in the
grand scheme of things versus just what
intelligence is in general one way of
thinking about what intelligence is is
as an optimization process the most
basic of all optimization processes is
evolution which is looking for good
replicators in the search space of
animals right or creatures organisms of
organism since the word and so it does
this by picking a point in the search
space a specific animal right and then
there are slight mutations when the
thing reproduces so it's moved slightly
in the search space right every time it
reproduces there's a slight shift
because the children are not exactly the
same as the parents and the way that it
evaluates the fitness function over the
whole search space is how many surviving
children that animal goes on to have
that's what it's optimizing for right so
it's very slow because it's movements
through the search space of random and
then it just is slightly more likely to
keep movements that are that are sort of
upward so one way of imagining it if
you've got a two-dimensional search
space suppose we have an animal that can
actually only vary in two ways with an
extremely simple type of animal at every
point in this search space there will be
a fitness level right which is this kind
of abstract concept of how good that
organism is at reproducing on average an
organism that has these attributes is
going to have how many surviving
children right so now we've behind have
got something three-dimensional you can
think of it as like a three-dimensional
surface right like it's got you know
it's like
some kind of mountain where there's
various hills and bumps this comes down
to here which is this and that and
that's the top of that mountain it's
what's called the hill climbing
algorithm and this is why I'm laying it
out in this particular way because it
climbs a hill it's like a blind person
and they try just stepping in one
direction at random and saying right am
i higher than I was and if they're
higher than they were then they stay
there and if not they step back and then
just try stepping randomly again and so
very gradually they will climb up the
mountain there is one problem with that
which I can show on this on the paper
here which is that if you are a basic
hill climbing algorithm like evolution
you can climb yourself
buh-buh-buh-buh-buh buhbuh you know
wandering around animate you eventually
get up to here and once you get here
you're actually stuck because it goes
down before it goes up even if there's a
huge mountain over there you can't see
the huge mountain you only see
immediately what's underneath you if you
have to get less fit before you get more
fit evolution isn't plan right so it
can't see that there's this huge hill
off in the distance so it gets stuck in
what's called a local maximum or a local
minimum which is a sort of a trap and
this happens to evolution fairly often
so that's an optimization process
optimization processes are about finding
high points on the fitness landscape and
if this were more than two dimensions if
this were you know 100,000 dimensions
the more dimensions you have the harder
it is right because you've got more
things to change and the whole thing
just becomes much more complex and
optimizing with more dimensions is
harder and this is a big problem in
machine learning in general that you end
up with with way too many dimensions and
you need to figure out ways of just
picking the dimensions that matter the
most or distilling them down
dimensionality reduction is called as a
whole thing in itself so are we saying
the mountains are just a how successful
each point on that graph is yes exactly
so it is a third dimension but it's not
a dimension of the configuration space
because each dimension is something that
you can check
change in terms of the design of the
organism or whatever evolution doesn't
have a direct there's no single how many
children do you have G right it's an
emergent property of everything else the
environment the way that the animal ends
up formed from all these different genes
the mountain ranges is just a way of
visualizing it you could also look at it
like a heat map just draw it on two
dimensions and shade it so that there's
like a red area around with there's an
orange area and a yellow area and so on
and you're trying to sort of head
towards the brightest area something
like that just different ways of
representing the same idea
one way of characterizing what an
intelligent system is is that it's good
at optimizing it has so evolution is is
not particularly good at optimizing for
good replicators but it you give it long
enough and it does a pretty good job but
our evolution is optimizing for
replication but you can you can draw
this type of mountain range or this heat
map or whatever for anything that's
interesting and an optimization
algorithm is trying to find the high
points in that space even if you're
still only looking at your local area
you can say well I took a step in this
direction and I went up so next time
rather than stepping completely randomly
I'm going to step in the same direction
again maybe even I'm going to step a
little bit further this time because I'm
assuming that this is a good direction
to headed and if I start heading down
again then I'll start looking randomly
again something like that there's always
a certain cost of doing an experiment as
it were
evolution does all of its experiments in
the real world right it can't think
whereas if I'm designing a car or
something I can say right what would
happen if I made it six inches longer we
can say well there'd be a bit more room
for this but they'd be less room for
that I'm thinking about it in my head I
don't need to build the car and a bunch
of choices that evolution would make in
its random meanderings don't even occur
to a human you know Oh what would happen
if you know we just broke off one of the
wing mirrors well you know that
immediately seems stupid and that's the
kind of thing that evolution might try a
few million times before it tries
something else and that's one of the key
differences and more powerful
intelligence is able to hit a smaller
space in a lot smaller target in a
larger search space
in less time which is why a car designer
is so much more intelligent than
evolution because a car designer can
make a change can make an improvement in
an afternoon which evolution couldn't
make in a hundred thousand years we'd
like to thank audible.com for sponsoring
this computer file video
they've got masses of books online to
choose from so if you want the chance to
try one out for free go to audible.com
slash computerphile
now today I'd like to recommend a book
called what-if which is by the creative
xkcd comics randall munroe it's also
narrated by Wil Wheaton I'm sure you all
know xkcd asks some of the questions
that have been posed to the xkcd
cartoonists over the years so get over
there audible.com slash computerphile
try out what if and thanks again to them
for sponsoring this film